and i think i think that's the important
thing because i've often said um
uh that
people get offended when they mistake
the subject of a joke with the actual
target yeah and they're not necessarily
the same thing you can make jokes about
any subject it depends what the joke is
yeah there's no there's no rules you
can't joke about this you can you should
you just can yeah okay um and there's
nothing sacred but people then they go
uh wow um yeah we shouldn't hurt
people's feelings well you can if their
feelings are wrong yeah you know yeah if
you don't like the facts get yeah don't
change the facts change the feelings yes
you know jaina i love you gi jane 2
can't wait to see it all right
[Applause]
oh richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
[Applause]
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
how arrogant are you to think that you
deserve to go through life with no one
ever saying anything that you don't
agree with or like i i want people to
stop saying that joke's offensive yeah i
wanted to start saying i found it
offensive because you've got our own
emotion because that's all it is you're
just telling me how you feel about it
yeah there's nothing intrinsically
offensive about this joke
out your
mouth
wow dude
yeah it was a gi janeja
i'm going to okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay